[Music]
the new england patriots getting ready
for sunday's game against the chargers a
little practice in the snow
lions fans familiar with that concept
even though the lions didn't actually
play in the snow the patriots could be
playing in the snow on sunday who knows
they may have some games in the elements
before super bowl 53 if they make it the
chargers have not lost a game away from
la this year gilbrant has a great point
with eight road wins including the
playoffs and a home win in london the
chargers became the eighth team since
the merger to win nine or more games
outside of their home stadium in a
season the other seven teams that have
done it have all won the super bowl wow
that's an impressive stat that really is
and you think about it the charge is
when you have no home field advantage
yes you're not flustered when you have
to play on the road you're always
playing on the road right at best you've
got half of the stadium that you play
your home games in occupied by visiting
fans you're used to the noise you're
used to distraction and it does
galvanize a team doesn't it definitely
without question mike you're exactly
right there yeah i mean the team they
just feel like they're being cheated or
not getting the respect they deserve
look we don't even get the respect at
home and yeah i wouldn't be shocked if
they always have to play with crowd
noise and practice where they bring out
big speakers and make you execute that
way because yeah there's been a number
of home games where you look up in the
stands and you go wow they are
completely outnumbered in the crowd in
the fan area but the chargers are a
complete football team and you know
again we've talked about the afc being
wide open i don't think either one of us
would be shocked if the
the the los angeles chargers went into
new england and won a football game i
mean uh and real in real talk the
chargers have been a more consistent
team all year long than the new england
patriots and there's some areas that
they certainly match up very well
against new england but the other thing
is it is new england with a week off and
they got some uh areas they match up
well with the chargers as well and now
you got belichick and mcdaniels with
extra time to prepare and they are
familiar with this defense and that's
where the matchup is intriguing road
game for the chargers road game for us
we're in kansas city getting ready for
the colts chief game tomorrow i'm
starving i cannot wait i think are we we
can't we can't eat during the
show that that's just not a good look oh
i won't okay yeah all right yeah maybe i
might take some i might order some food
and take some bites during commercial
breaks or something you know it's funny
any time i've ever seen a show like that
where they like eat during the show and
i think how stupid that is we may find
ourselves right in the middle of that
today so yeah it depends upon how good
it looks i do feel kind of seinfeld this
year right here you know it's like i'm
i'm jerry and you're george and this is
great you really i'm yeah
at least let me be creamer okay fine all
right you can be crazy you don't want to
be elaine no no i'll take kramer uh i'll
take newman i mean
i was like
newman so uh
we you talked about rob gronkowski
earlier yeah and that catch he made
against the chiefs right that sealed the
game right that back and forth one of
the best games the regular season and at
that moment i thought you know what
is that the last significant play we saw
from gronk all year and will we see
anything from him he still looks the
same yes but he hasn't played the same
can he get back to the guy that we're
accustomed to because they're going to
need that if they want to beat the
charge they are going to need that
certainly and i think uh no i don't know
if we're ever going to see the same rob
gronkowski that we've seen in years past
i don't i mean i definitely think
there's been a you know a little drop in
his uh
talent level or explosiveness ability to
separate and one-on-one coverage all of
those let alone i think you and i
probably 50 times this year have just
talked about that rob gronkowski doesn't
seem as emotionally invested in the
games like we've seen in years past and
hey he still might be but you know
usually he just showed us so such
excitement talking to defenders who were
trying to tackle him you know being real
animated when he scored a touchdown and
doing the hard you know hard spike of
the ball we have not seen that and i'm
fascinated by this match uh by rob
gronkowski and what he does one because
the the patriots want to run the ball
two
unlike the ravens of last week the
patriots have a million play action
passes off their run game which can make
rob gronkowski of course more dangerous
but the other factor in this is the guy
we love on the other side of the ball
derwin james who was already in the
conversation with one of the best
safeties in football he is the type of
player that in some man-to-man
situations can really give a rob
gronkowski a tough time remember when he
slid in round one back in april people
were like why is darwin james still on
the board right and he really has been a
guy who's coming contributed right away
for the charges made them better yep and
remember they this isn't a shock they
were nine and three down the stretch
last year right after they started off
the year 004 they go 9-3 in the final
12. and there was a great exchange
earlier this week between bill belichick
and reporters they were saying you know
how surprised are you the chargers have
gotten so much better this year they
they were nine and three down the
stretch last year right and they asked
them a similar question like i just said
they were nine and three yes i don't
worry about the other the four losses to
start the season yeah this is a team
that turned it around mid-stream and has
continued it all the way into the second
season and and to to play the way they
have especially on the road something's
got to give chargers haven't lost a game
outside of l.a right the patriots
haven't lost at home right and tom
brady's never lost to philip rivers yes
so a streak is going to end in a major
way on sunday and it won't surprise me
if the chargers win i i've i've got to
lean patriots of course because i feel
like the patriots are going to get some
extra motivation from the fact that
there's a perception that they're at the
end of the road and that the time has
passed them by that tom brady is finally
having his skills diminished that gronk
isn't gronk anymore sure and i think
bill belichick will know how to push
those buttons just the right way to get
those guys to be ready to go and ready
to go out and prove to everyone they
still have it yeah i mean uh certainly
he's the master motivator bill belichick
they're massive snipe combat here there
yeah right exactly i mean hey listen my
time up there i know that you know wes
welker the the coaching staff you know
they used to say bill would you know
kind of needle wes welker just because
they felt like he played better when he
was a little angry so bill knows the
buttons to push certainly hey and
they'll also know if we win this
football game there's a very real chance
that we know the colts could maybe beat
the chiefs and they could be hosting an
afc championship game as well um the
rivalry really would be back it really
would be back on and i really i
envisioned this being more of an a
defensive type game
unlike the other af afc game i think
this one is more in the 20 to 17 23 20
range i don't know how you feel about it
but uh the chargers offense has not been
playing very well as of late they've
been sputtering down the stretch and the
the patriots secondary mic that's where
i look at one of the strengths of their
football team they have one of the best
secondaries in the sport this rookie j.c
jackson along with stefan gilmour
they're going to be able to match up on
those receivers and then maybe they
double team akeena allen on third down
that's the the chess match i'm excited
to watch the thing about the patriots
when everything is going well we don't
notice it right when it goes poorly oh
oh
right but they stabilized after the
losses to miami and pittsburgh they won
the last two games of the regular season
they end up with a buy
and now they may be hosting the afc
championship game or coming here to
kansas city next week and having a
pretty good chance at beating the chiefs
the site of the on to cincinnati game
from 2014. exactly right i mean that
would be an ultimate redemption that
might be the matchup i look forward to
seeing
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports